these kids tried to kill themselves 12
times and they failed and they failed
oh my gosh
[Music]
I spent probably two hours just reading
about this person oh uh when I when it
came across this article about this guy
named Larry Ray
I was like this sounds like a long story
and I could not stop reading it so I
encourage everybody who hears about this
We're not gonna be able to cover all of
it because it's insane but read about
Larry Ray and figure out what he did at
Sarah Lawrence liberal arts college
because it's insane what did he learn
about lesbian dance
is that what they do at those colleges
so this guy right
uh this this college is called Sarah
Lawrence uh college in New York it's
liberal arts
um this dude ends up moving in with his
daughter at her dorm what yeah but it's
weird because
no it's not I don't think so because
it's age restricted right you try to be
the R.A or what for students yeah you
can't do that but the crazy thing is
that this daughter his daughter that's
going there she's been talking about her
dad forever it's like my dad's this
amazing person he he was like uh he blew
the whistle on the CIA and did all they
he they kind of regard him as this like
liberal hero so they respect him before
even meeting him kind of deal yeah why
why is he like a prominent member like
in the liberal Community he's done a lot
of like governmental things that are
kind of like anti-government but
um it's not what you think it is so it's
not like Biden liberal it's like
off the French liberal like what I don't
get it uh that's kind of so he's a
legend somehow is what I'm trying to
point at like well it's not true oh
they're lying it is but it isn't so he
he actually so that that's the crazy
thing is in all the reports that you see
it's gonna seem like oh this guy just
lied he stretched it but he didn't lie
it's super stretched oh okay so what
happened is he arrives at this college
everyone's so happy that he's gonna move
in I think there's like six of them in
this dorm
um in this like little house that they
all share
um they they're excited he's gonna come
because they love the idea of this guy
like uh Larry Ray he's like in his um I
think he's in his 50s at the time that
he moves in extra weird wait what
liberal arts college is like um isn't
that like like like an alternative
school it's not like high school but
it's like the special high school that
focuses on like all the Arts it's a
college for Liberal Arts your major is
going to be something in Liberal Arts
yeah Oh I thought it was the liberal
arts college is it a college for Liberal
Arts oh no no because I thought like
it's like you know in the UK they call
high school college and [__] and then
it's like never mind uh this is in New
York okay never mind uh so UK guy what
happens here is he moves in with them
and then they just admire this guy so
much he kind of starts to become this
father figure for all these kids he's
[__] he's [__] young young [__]
dude he is [__] the [__] out of these
18 year olds it's insane the fact that
you want to move in with your daughter
and her dorm that is the route to people
every person who has opened up a cult
that is what they do yeah if you want
Enlightenment suck my dick yep that's
exactly what he's doing
Bikram Yoga let's start with that that's
why this is one of my favorite Cults
here JK yeah dude how many times has he
suck dick dude the crazy thing is is
they actually because they are so
vulnerable uh all of these kids has a
history of depression
um of course they're liberal arts
of course you know I know we make jokes
but for reals which is like I hate to
say it but like when you read the the
full story every one of these kids has
so many like self issues oh and like um
so what happens is he gets these like
kids kind of under his wing and then it
just gets so intense where
um he starts making them write these
like apology notes whenever he claims
they damage something in the house which
he's making up entirely he'll be like oh
someone broke the stove hey you did it
you now have to like write this thing
and they would just obey his every
command [__] you dude it becomes this
abusive like cult uh situation where he
starts forcing them into doing things uh
it becomes uh like public affiliation
where you had this one kid there's one
on patreon but he had this one dude like
uh he this one dude felt like he might
be gay so and he kept telling him he's
not gay and then he forced him to like
wear a dress and get the mail and then
forced him to like force him to jam a
dildo at himself in front of everyone
while everyone laughed
to like how is that gonna help him not
be gay he would make these things up
that would make him more good and when
they meet more gay yeah he alienated
them from all their families like what
always happens
in the total count from the time that
this happened to the time that it ended
these kids tried to kill themselves 12
times oh and they failed yeah
yeah I did oh my gosh
some of them were on like prior to
meeting him some of them were already on
anti-psychotic medication why is there
so
there's such College liberal arts baby
that's that's dry said my craziest thing
is that he managed to trick one of the
girls uh for for four years he managed
to trick her into thinking that she had
tried to poison him what so to make
amends for that just a second he forced
her to into prostitution in which she
made for him 2.5 million dollars in
those four years
girl must be hot as [__] or she works a
lot high and dumb or is it a numbers
game yeah high volume Liz I'm not making
a joke I'm serious like do you have any
idea like how much he would have to
charge for her like she must be really
beautiful dude because she's making only
fans money but she's doing it in real
life for over four years the list of
what he made these kids do is so
insanely long and it lasts so how come
nobody was like why is this 50 year old
living in the dorm that's another thing
so the dean of students who's supposed
to blow the whistle on that he was a fan
he kept saying I can't do anything about
it because parents have the right to
visit their kids and they would just say
oh he's not he didn't live here he's
just visiting because they like them but
then the dean's like yeah I can't do
anything about it that's her dad wow and
that guy's on record like in this whole
case is like having not done anything
when he he was supposed to but the crazy
thing is in that school they're so
tolerant about everything that they
never because it's too liberal I mean
the word liberal is like [__] just
accept it all what's the actual
definition of liberal like chill right
everybody's chill one of these people
one of these kids I call them kids with
the you know they're one of the dudes
had had two sisters that he introduced
to Larry oh no older sisters that were
very like educated one of them had
already finished med school and was in
like a residency to be a doctor she quit
that to be with Larry Ray oh he's and
became one of his like slaves wow damn
listen this guy's a cult leader dude how
does he do it that's the crazy thing so
if you read the full story it details
every single thing he did and you start
to go oh [__] like it's the real
step-by-step thing and the Slow Burn and
the trickle to get their minds to change
and you are really like this guy's a
master and then I want to see this
sociopath I want to say it's crazy
I want to see how they work so the crazy
thing is in the beginning you think
about all the [__] that he's bragging
about you're like okay sure you did then
the journalist goes into the actual true
records of what he really did do and
it's almost as impressive it's just not
accurate so that's how he can lie wow he
was connected to him he uh was connected
to Rudy Giuliani Donald Trump uh loads
of like really important people he
helped some guy become the the police
commissioner of New York and when that
guy didn't save him from this case he
ruined that guy's life and he had to
like step down what though he had [__]
so he had dirt on people yeah so the
thing that you read he detailed how he
manipulated it it's all literally to the
almost like to the day like what he did
and how he did it wow now all of these
kids are off that spell uh I don't know
about the daughter but all these kids
escaped eventually the whole mentality
and they now realize what was happening
and they've all put their stories
together and he has now been uh
prosecuted he's 63 now and he's he just
got sentenced the other day to 60 years
in jail is he is he is he
no he's not he just looks like a a bald
big white guy how the [__] did he do
he's gonna be a Netflix dog he's not
sure I can't wait for this Netflix
documentary because I gotta know about
it yeah there's gonna be there has to be
a dog because it's it's so intense and
the crazy thing is like he's a social he
just understood how to pray on the
mentalities of vulnerable young people
to where he became this guide it was the
craziest thing and he would make them
have sex with each other and he would
watch and then he made his landlord come
and join and [__] them it's the weirdest
[__] wow dude and his daughter is just
like in the middle daughter entirely
complicit in the entire thing that's why
she's probably like yeah my dad's
awesome he's gonna come in yeah is she
gonna get any punishment is she involved
I believe she's a co-defendant she has
to I believe she's either a co-defendant
or someone else is a co-defendant
because uh the crazy thing is they look
at his whole like activity sheet from
even pre Sarah Lawrence College and that
whole thing and every person he's come
in contact with he was able to so
successfully scam them that the people
that were gonna assess his mentality
didn't want to do it because they
thought he would get them too
like the professional people that are
gonna be like is this guy crazy enough
let's run a test they were refusing to
test it this [__] just got mind
control Powers you're just afraid he's
so good that we're at risk that's like
some Charles Manson level isn't that
wish a [__] would dude isn't
that scary dude next thing you know
you're all sucking his dick I know
there's like a clip of me leaving his
office dude he didn't do it so just
remember this story of Larry Ray like
that's gonna come back around in a real
big way because now how did you find
this one up it was just a headline that
oh Larry Ray got set into 60 years it
was like a big deal and I'm like why and
then there was just this long it was
just so fascinating probably it took me
two hours to read the whole thing and I
was like you gotta send me that stuff
man I'm so curious I really need to
learn how to do this
does he have a master class that we
could join it's almost the young people
thing just to learn how to like control
people like that that's pretty crazy or
live in a dorm yeah pretty nice you get
cafeteria food downstairs I missed that
life even the parents so even even the
parents of these kids when they found
out what was happening would go to
confront him and then suck his dick up
they would end up writing him checks
he had gotten at least at least two
hundred thousand dollars from some of
these parents in overtime even though
they knew that he was manipulating them
and they would try to stop it he would
flip it somehow and they would end up
paying it dude I gotta know he knows he
knows voodoo magic yeah there's no
[__] voice but you know what though
he's dealing with white people I want to
see him do this to a Chinese Aunt oh
impossible dude that's true impossible
he probably knows the crowd he could do
this yeah they were
the thermostat
you're not a real money guy
there's no record of him interacting
with anyone Asian actually at 62 degrees
Hispanic or English Hispanic Hispanic
Indian sounds like it's just white white
you know getting the Indian Auntie to
pay him 200 Grand is a pretty big deal
really good dude this guy's good I think
it was the in it might have been the
Indian person that quit med school or
quit The Residency it might have been
and then became one of his like
girlfriends there's like two that he had
oh my God yeah it's crazy he's like the
he's like a better version of Andrew
Tate
like he can manipulate the [__] out of
these people like with actual accounts
dude if you just got a YouTube channel
the fact that they the fact that they're
willing to legally state that every
person in his record that he came in
contact with was a victim is crazy they
were like he doesn't have one person he
even though that's a textbook social
path yeah even the place where he lived
like his apartment that he had in New
York was given to him by a person that
he eventually uh backstabbed in the in
the future it's it's so easy not one to
say I wouldn't know this personally
because I've never done this right but
you know people who who are falling into
like really dark times and they're just
looking for anybody to give them like a
little speck of light and they see it
and they attach onto it that's how a lot
of people join Cults yeah like
overzealous religious people they were
in the worst part of their life and
they're like well this religion saved me
it's like or you were just in the
shittiest place on Earth and the right
person at the right time said the right
thing yeah and they just start taking
everything from you and you're just so
grateful from that one moment that they
saved you here that whatever you give to
them is is never enough for what they
gave right right and I've seen that
happen so many times I know a a personal
friend from high school she used to have
so many issues with her mom because she
was so devout Buddhist she would give
like 50 of their income to the temple
and 50 and they were [__] so [__]
poor because of it not if they kept that
money they would have been perfectly
fine but her mom kept giving half of
their income to the [__] Temple and
so when what would they get in this
stage like a mother monk would come over
and bless their place but then she would
get so frustrated because she's like
until this day this is why she's super
agnostic She [__] hates religion
because that part ruined her life
because her mom believed she was such a
devout Buddhist that she she was she
felt that her mother her mom would
rather have her family suffer and give
it to this Temple than take care that's
like why the guy killed Shinzo Abe
because of the unification Church
yeah so if you guys ever have time read
the story or wait till the uh
documentary comes out I'm sure it's
being made now but it the the scariest
thing truly is reading the notes and the
accounts and feeling manipulated
yourself because you're like oh it's
such a slow drip I swear it's like when
you read it as a whole it doesn't affect
you but when you get these first person
accounts of what he's saying to them
word for word and what he does to them
like word for word you start to feel
like
oh dude this guy's a tactician of like a
highest degree so the more you read it
were you like dang I'm gonna go [__]
write a checks for this guy you're
running a check as you're reading it and
you go suck his dick Larry Ray